السلام عليكم ورحمه الله قبل الرئيس
الفلسطيني محمود عباس استقاله رامل حمد
الله من رئاسه الوزراء وكلفه بمواصله عمله
رئيس لحكومه تصريف اعمال لمده خمسه اسابيع
جاء ذلك بعدما اصر الحمد الله على
الاستقاله اثر تنازع على الصلاحيات مع
نائبيه المعينين من الرئاسه الفلسطينيه
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر ناقشه في
محورين ما طبيعه العلاقه الجدليه في
النظام السياسي الفلسطيني بين رئيس السلطه
ورئيس
حكومته وما خيارات انهاء هذا الجدل
وارتباطه بملف المصالحه الفلسطينيه وجهود
استئناف مفاوضات السلام مع
اسرائيل
استقاله رامي الحمد الله من رئاسه الحكومه
الفلسطينيه الجديده في رام الله بعد 18
يوما فقط من توليه منصبه تفتح ملف علاقه
شائكه بين رئيس السلطه الفلسطينيه ورؤساء
الحكومات غلفها نزاع دائم على الصلاحيات
بدا منذ دفعت الضغوط الامريكيه الرئيس
الراحل ياسر عرفات الى استحداث منصب رئيس
الوزراء واسناده الى الرئيس الحالي محمود
عباس عام
2003 وبقيت العلاقه الشائكه قائمه بين
عباس
وحكوماته جاءت استقاله رئيس الوزراء
الفلسطيني رامل حمد الله في وقت حرج وعامر
باسئله كثيره تدور في الشارع الفلسطيني
وخارجه بعضها يتعلق بشكل وقوه الفلسطيني
الذي سيتفاوض مع اسرائيل اذا حدث ذلك
وكثير منها يتعلق الوحده الفلسطينيه
المفقوده سبب رحيل حكومه الحمد الله بعد
18 يوما فقط من تشكيلها هو ذات الداء
العضال الذي قضى على عدد من الحكومات
الفلسطينيه بما فيها الحكومه الاولى
برئاسه محمود عباس والمتعلق بضباب صلاحيات
رئيس الحكومه وتضاربها احيانا مع صلاحيات
اخرين يضاف الى ذلك غموض اختصاصات المنصب
نفسه الذي انشئ اصلا عام 2003 حينما رفضت
اسرائيل وامريكا التفاوض الم
مع رئيس السلطه الراحل ياسر عرفات ورغم
تغير الزمان والاشخاص والاحداث ظلت هيمنه
السلطه على الحكومه قائمه كان ذلك من
بواعث خلاف السلطه مع اول حكومه منتخبه
برئاسه اسماعيل هنيه اقالها الرئيس عباس
في يونيو عام 2007 ليدخل الفلسطينيون حاله
الانقسام المزعج بكل تداعياته السالبه
المستمره حتى اليوم الشارع السياسي
الفلسطيني الراهن يعيش تعقيدات مختلفه
حماس اعتبرت استقال الحمد الله وقبولها من
قبل الرئيس يعكس عمق ازمه مؤسسات السلطه
والحل برايها ان تنطلق من هذه الاستقاله
مرحله بناء مؤسسات السلطه على اسس
ديمقراطيه ووطنيه وان يتم التطبيق التام
لاتفاق الدوحه والقاهره كذلك فان المطلوب
من الفلسطينيين وبضغط متزايده العوده الى
التفاوض مع اسرائيل ربما دون البد في
المطالب التي يتمسك بها الرئيس عباس منذ
2010 في ظل هذه التعقيدات ما هي ار الرئيس
المتاحه وما مدى امكانيه جنوحه لسد ما
يستطيع من ثغرات بتشكيله مثلا حكومه
كفاءات وطنيه برئاسته حسب الاتفاقات
السابقه مع حماس عموما الساحه مفتوحه على
مصرعها امام مختلف
الاحتمالات موضوع حلقتنا هذه نناقشه مع
ضيوفنا من رام الله الكاتب المحلل السياسي
غسال الخطيب ومن غزه الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي مصطفى الصواف وعبر الهاتف من
برلين عزام الاحمد عضو اللجنه المركزيه
لحركه فتح مرحبا بضيوفنا الكرام استاذ
عزام الاحمد الرئيس اختار رئيس وزراء وعين
الى جانبه نائبين بصلاحيات واسعه في
الملفين
الشائك الاقتصادي والسياسي هل كانت
الرئاسه تريد رئيس
وزراء شكليا سوريا كما ذهب البعض
لا حقيقه ليس بهذه
الصوره اولا الجانب
السياسي
ل السلطه الوطنيه لا علاقه لها بالشان
السياسي هي
وحكومتها الشان السياسي هو من اختصاص
منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه وهذا ليس بدعه
حديثه وانما منذ قيام السلطه وحتى اليوم
لم تتدخل الحكومات المتعاقبه بالشان
السياسي اطلاقا انا شاركت بست حكومات او
سبع حكومات لم نكن طرف لا بمفاوضات ولا
بعلاقات سياسيه منظمه التحرير هي المعنيه
بالشان السياسي طيب الشان الاقتصادي استاذ
احمد عزام احمد الشان الاقتصادي وضح لك
نعم انا وقت التشكيل معلوماتي الرئيس ابو
مازن لغ ذلك للدكتور رامل حمد الله ان
الدكتور محمد مصطفى نائب رئيس وزراء سيكون
مشرف على الشان الاقتصادي ولكن باشراف
رئيس الوزراء وهذا ما اكده امس الرئيس ابو
مازن للدكتور رامل حمض الله في لقائه مساء
امس قال له انت مسؤول عن الحكومه بكاملها
نواب و وزراء وانت مسؤول امامي وبالتالي
لا يوجد نزاع مع الرئيس
اطلاقا ربما اجتهادات بعض التصرفات
الفرديه من
نواب الوزراء وبعض الوزراء جعلت ولكن ولكن
استاذ عزام احمد عذر المقاطعه ولكن اشرح
لي انت ما تردد في الاعلام الفلسطيني يعني
بعض الفلسطينيين قالوا بان رئيس السلطه
الفلسطينيه خاطب المصرفين الدوليين
المعروفين البنك الدولي وصندوق النقد
الدولي باعتماد توقيع السيد محمد مصطفى
نائب رئيس الوزراء في التعاملات الماليه
يعني هذا الامر هو الذي اغضب الحنظله كما
ردد
الفلسطينيون يعني انا بقول لك بشكل واضح
منذ قيام
السلطه
حتى هذه اللحظه لم يكن رئيس الوزراء طرف
في العلاقه مع البنك الدولي انما يكون طرف
من خلال وزرائه المعنيين وزير الماليه
وزير التخطيط بشكل اساسي واحيانا وزير
الاقتصاد حتى الدكتور سلام فياط عندما كان
يشارك كان يشارك بصفته وزير ماليه وليس
بصفته رئيس وزراء
وبالتالي كان هناك نشاط محدد الرئيس ابو
مازن طلب منه اذن الدكتور محمد مصطفى وسمح
له لذلك الدكتور رامل حمد الله شعل عرب
الانفعال وارسل
استقاله بتقديري بطريقه خاطئه كان على
الدكتور رامي ان يذهب بنفسه الى الرئيس
ابو مازن ويتفاهم معه افضل من ان نقع
بالصوره التي نحن فيها الان استاذ مصطفى
صواف الكاتب والمحلل السياسي من غزه
اسماعيل هانيه كانت له تجربه مماثله مع
الرئيس محمود عباس انتهت باقالته عام 2007
بعد خلافات حول شؤون
الماليه والسياسيه هل ترى انت اي تشابه
بين ما جرى و وسيناريو حند الله وكيف تصف
الازمه
الحاليه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم يعني
اعتقد ان نزاع الصلاحيات ليس من اليوم حتى
منذ اللحظه الاولى التيعين فيها رئيس
وزراء في عهد الراحل ياسر عرفات وكان اول
رئيس وزراء هو السيد محمود عباس واستقال
بعد ان د ياسر عرفات الاستحواذ بالكامل
على الحكومه وتحريكها بالطريقه التي يراها
فلذلك وجد نفسه بانه اشبه بخيال مجاتا
يعني بمعنى انه لا لزوم له فلذلك قدم
الاستقاله ما يجري الان مع الحمض الله
ايضا مختلف عما كان مع اسماعيل هنيه في
عام 2007 خاصه ان اقاله اسماعيل هنيه جاءت
بعد احداث الانقسام او بعد
احداث المعارك بين الاجهزه الامنيه
الفلسطينيه وبين حكومه حماس لذ عزم احمد
يقول استاذ صواف استاذ عزام احمد يقول كما
سمعت ان الملف السياسي دائما كان بيد
منظمه التحرير والملف الاقتصادي لم يكن
يوما يعني من صلاحيه رئيس الوزراء بشكل
كامل وانما كان يشرف على هذه
الملفات الملف الاقتصادي على الاقل هو من
صلاحيات رئيس الوزراء سلام فياض قبل
استقالته كان يشرب بشكل كامل على الوضع اص
بوصفه وزير الماليه يقول الاستاذ عزم احمد
وليس بوصفه رئيس الوزراء نعم حتى
حتى حتى لو كان هناك مكلف بالشان
الاقتصادي لابد ان يتلقى تعليماته من رئيس
الوزراء وليس من رئيس السلطه وان تكون
علاقته بشكل مباشر والا ما
فائده اهم ملفين وهما الشان السياسي
والشان الاقتصادي لا علاقه له بهما وكذلك
الشان الامني بمعنى وزاره الداخليه
والاجهزه الامنيه ايض ايضا لا علاقه له
بها فلذلك هو يريد بهذه الطريقه سيتحول
رامي الحمض الله الى رئيس بلديه كبرى وليس
لرئيس حكومه وهذا هو السبب الذي ربما دفع
به الى تقديم استقالات مبكرا استاذ غسان
الخطيب انت كنت وزيرا سابقا وخبيره العمل
الحكومي نريد ان نعرف منك رؤيتك انت من
خلال تجربتك تلك لطبيعه العلاقه هذه
الشائكه الملتبس بين رئيس الوزراء
وا الرئيس الفر
صيني الواقع ان القانون الاساسي والقوانين
الساريه تحدد بشكل واضح لا لبس فيه
الصلاحيات لكل من الموقعين وفي راي
المشكله تكمن في تجاوز القانون الاساسي
الذي هو بمثابه الدستور واعتقد بانه هذه
الحكومه يعني استقالت بسرعه وحصلت هذه
الازمه بشكل سريع لان هذه الحكومه شكلت
بطريقه فيها تجاوزات قانون
القانون الاساسي يسمح لرئيس الوزراء
تحديدا ان يتخذ نائبا له ان يعين نائبا له
من بين اعضاء مجلس الوزراء في الحاله التي
حصلت الرئيس ومن خلال مرسوم التعيين ك
يعني عين رئيس الوزراء وعين نائبين له
وليس نائبا واحدا وبالتالي تعيين نائب
الرئيس لم ياتي من رئيس الوزراء بل اتى من
الرئيس مما احدث لبسا وثانيا
يعني تكليف احد نواب الوز احد نواب رئيس
الوزراء بالملف الاقتصادي في الوقت الذي
يكون فيه وزير اقتصاد يحمل حقيبه الاقتصاد
ويكون فيه وزير ماليه ايضا مسؤول عن بعض
يعني النواحي الذي لها على في الاقتصاد
هذا بحد ذاته وصفه
لمشاكل وبالتالي يعني برايي حدثت هذه
الازمه نتيجه عدم الالتزام الدقيق
بالقانون الاساسي الذي هو بمثابه الدستور
هل مع ذلك استاذ غسان ان
ان السيد محمد مصطفى كان مكلفا بالملف
الاقتصادي لدى ديوان الرئاسه بينما وزير
الاقتصاد يعمل مع رئيس
الوزراء بشكل
صوري يعني يعني لا ادري ولكن يعني في ظاهر
الامر نعم يعني هناك شخصين في نفس الحكومه
كل منهما يحمل نفس الملف وا ايضا
يعني نواب الرئيس يجب نواب نائب رئيس
الوزراء يجب ان يكون معين من رئيس الوزراء
حتى يكون مسؤولا امام رئيس الوزراء اما ان
اما ان يتم تعيين نواب الرئيس ورئيس
الوزراء في ان واحد من
قبل الرئيس فهذا ايضا الى حد ما وكانه يضع
رئيس الوزراء ونوابه الى حد ما على قدم
وساق وهذا هو ايضا ما احدث
اللبس المخرج من ذلك انه في المرات الق
القادمه يجب ان يكون هناك التزام دقيق
بالنصوص القانونيه وبالقانون الاساسي ولكن
الاحل من
ذلك بما في صلاحيات لانه القانون الاساسي
يحدد الصلاحيات الى حد بعيد
المساله المساله هي في طيب نريد ان افهم
منك كوزير ومطالع على هذا القانون الاساسي
رئيس الوزراء ما حدوده يعني هامش تحركه في
الملف الاقتصادي
والسياسي رئيس الوزراء له المسؤوليه
الكامله في الملف الاقتصادي وينفذ ذلك
احيانا بشكل مباشر من خلال من خلاله هو
نفسه واحيانا من خلال وزرائه وبشكل خاص
وزيري الاقتصاد والماليه اما الناحيه
السياسيه فما يتعلق بالمفاوضات السياسيه
والقضايا السياسيه البحته هي فعلا مسؤوليه
منظمه التحرير ولكن في بعض الجوانب هناك
تداخل
اي الحكومه ورئيسها ايضا لديهم مسؤوليه
معينه فيما يتعلق بالعلاقات السياسيه مع
الدول
الاخرى خصوصا ما يتعلق بقضايا العلاقه مع
الدول المانحه اذ ان هناك تداخل في
العلاقات بطابعها المختلف سواء كانت
اقتصاديه او غير اقتصاديه مع الدول الاخرى
يعني هذا هذا الامر استاذ غسان هذا الامر
نفسه الذي كان يشتكي منه محمود عباس حينما
كان رئيسا لاول حكومه في عهد الرئيس
الراحل ياسي عرفات وهنا توجه الاستاذ عزام
الاحمد يعني
الرئيس عباس نفسه استقال من رئاسه الحكومه
عام
2 و3 بسبب خلافات الصلاحيات مع الرئيس
عرفات هل نحن اذا امام ازمه مزمنه في
النظام السياسي الفلسطيني كما وصفها البعض
وورثها الرئيس محمود عباس من نظام
سابق لا الامر ليس كذلك نهائيا وانا اذكر
الدكتور غسان اول نائب رئيس وزراء كنت انا
شخصيا نائب لرئيس وزراء حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه كنت نائبا لاسماعيل هنيه في حكومه
الوحده الوطنيه اذا ليست هي الم بترشيح
من نعم بترشيح من بترشيح
الرئيس هي بدي اوضحها الرئيس هو الذي يصدر
مرسوم بالتشكيل بعد الاتفاق مع رئيس
الوزراء وهكذا تم مع السيد اسماعيل هنيه
بعد عندما شكلت حكومه الوحده الوطنيه وكنت
نائبا له وايضا الحكومه الحاليه لم يعين
الرئيس ابو مازن النائبين بمعزل عن
الدكتور رامل حمد الله وانما الدكتور رامل
الحمض الله قدم التشكيله النهائيه طبعا
بعد اجراء المشاورات و من ضمنهم النائبين
ولكن انا شخصيا لاحظت منذ تعيين نائبين
وبعض الكتاب الفلسطينيين يغمز هنا وهناك و
مما خلق اجواء وكان هناك صراع على
الصلاحيات وهذا غير دقيق رئيس الوزراء له
صلاحيات كامله على نائبه او نوابه يعني
حتى عندما يعين نائبين هذا ليس مخالف
للقانون اطلاقا القانون الاساسي يقول بان
الرئيس الوزراء هو من يعين نائبه وليس
رئيس الدوله رئيس كل الوزراء كل ان سمحت
لي كل الوزراء بغض النظر من رشحهم الذي
يقدم الترشيح النهائي لهم امام الرئيس هو
رئيس الوزراء المكلف سنبحث محمد مصطفى
وضحت فكره استاذ عز احمد سنبحث بعد ف فاصل
قصير خيارات حل ازمه الصلاحيات هذه وكل
الالتباس والغموض الذي يحيط بها وارتباطها
بملف المصالحه الفلسطينيه وجهود استئناف
محدثه السلام بعد هذا الفاصل فابقوا معنا
مشاهدينا
الكرام اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا الكرام
في هذه الحلقه التي تناقش قضيه تنازع
الصلاحيات في السلطه الفلسطينيه في ضوء
قبول استقاله رئيس الوزراء الجديد رامي
الحمد الله استاذ مصطفى الصواف القيادي في
حركه حمال صلاح بردويل ق اكد ان ازمه
الصلاحيات التي تقف خلف استقاله الحمض
الله ترتبط بمشروع سياسي
متكامل هل هذا يشي بان النظام السياسي
الفلسطيني القائم الان يتعارض مع مسار
المصالحه الذي تبتغيه حماس والفصائل التي
تشارك في هذه
العمليه المساله ليست هي تعارض ما بين
المشروع السياسي الذي يريد السيد محمود
عباس تنفيذه على ارض الواقع مع الجانب
الامريكي الاسرائيلي ولكن المساله ان
السيد محمود عباس ليس جاهزا الان لتحقيق
ملف المصالحه والالتزام بما تم الاتفاق
عليه في اتفاق القاهره وجدولت التي كانت
واضحه امام الجميع مساله النظام السياسي
يمكن ان يتغير في هذا المجال ويمكن
التوافق من قبل الكل الفلسطيني على طبيعه
هذا النظام السياسي الذي لم يتم حتى هذه
اللحظه وهذه ن
خلافيه الكل الفلسطيني سواء بين فتح وحماس
وبقيه القوى وغيرها فلذلك الموضوع الاهم
هو ان يكون هناك قاعده ينطلق من خلالها
الفلسطينيون نحو تحقيق نظام
سياسي يؤسس لمرحله قادمه فيها نوع من
الشراكه السياسيه قائمه على مصالح وحقوق
الشعب الفلسطيني لذلك انا ارى ان النظام
السياسي يمكن اعاده صياغته مره اخرى
فيوافق فلسطيني فلسطيني وفق القانون الا
الساس الفلسطيني الذي يتم تجاوزه في كل
المراحل القائمه منذ سنوات طويله نعم
استاذ غسان الخطيب هل تعتقد بان الازمه
الحاليه قد يكون لها تداعيات على مسار
عمليه المصالحه وهل تعني ان الرئيس محمود
عباس ليس في عجله من امره في المضي بعيدا
في هذا
المسار اولا اعتقد بانه اذا بقينا بدون
انتخابات وبدون مجلس تشريعي
يضمن ويكفل التزام السلطات التنفيذيه
المختلفه بالقانون الاساسي و يعطي او يسحب
الثقه من الحكومه بناء على كونه الممثل
للشعب الفلسطيني فستستمر هذه الازمات
الحكوميه وستتصدى
ظروف اكثر صعوبه من الظروف الحاليه لذلك
انا اعتقد انه على المدى المتوسط والبعيد
الطريقه الوحيده للخروج من هذه الاز زمات
الحكوميه المتتاليه هو في ضروره الذهاب
الى الانتخابات لكي يعود لنا مجلس تشريعي
منتخب يمارس صلاحياته في ضمان تنفيذ
القانون الاساسي الذي وضعه هو
الض من يفترض ان ان يدعو الى يجب ان ي يجب
ان يج الانتخابات تدم بدعوه من الرئيس
والان المعيق لذلك هو موضوع الانقسام لذلك
انا في اعتقادي انه موضوع حل الانقسام
وموضوع الاجراء الاجراء الانتخابات هو
ضروره وطنيه ملحه وما وان لم وان لم تتم
الانتخابات ويجب ان لا نستمر بالتذرع
موضوع الانقسام بالتهرب من
الانتخابات يجب اعطاء فرصه لتحقيق
المصالحه ومن ثم الانتخابات ولكن اذا لم
يكن هناك فرصه لتحقيق المصالحه فيجب اجراء
الانتخابات على كل الاحوال استاذ عزام
الاحمد لماذا لم ينتظر الرئيس محمود عباس
ان يكون هناك توافق على شروط المصالحه ان
يبدا تنفيذ ما تم الاتفاق عليه لتشكيل
حكومه جديده وفق اعلان الدوحه
مثلا ارجو ان يتاح للوقت لسماع الرد كاملا
تفضل كان من المقرر يوم
14/5 الماضي ان نلتقي في القاهره مع
الاخوه في حماس
والتقينا اثناء استقاله الدكتور سلام فياض
من اجل بدء المشاورات
لتشكيل حكومه التوافق الوطني برئاسه
الرئيس محمود عباس تنفيذا لاعلان الدوحه
وذهبنا الى القاهره واجتمعنا ولكن الاخوه
في حماس لم يكونوا جاهزين فاقترحوا علينا
برنامج عمل مدته ثلاثه اشهر تنتهي يوم
14/8 وهذا بحضور المصريين ومكتوب ووب خطيا
وتم الاتفاق في ضوء ذلك على تاجيل موضوع
حكومه التوافق الوطني فاضطر الرئيس محمود
عباس لتشكيل حكومه الدكتور رامل حمد الله
لانه لا يجوز ترك فراغ قانوني اخر يوم
لحكومه الدكتور سلام فياط كان هو اثنين 6
من الشهر الجاري الان اذا تذكرون عندما
اعلن تشكيل حكومه الدكتور رامي الحمض الله
رامي الحمض الله شخصيا اعلن وعبر الجزيره
وغيرها ان حكومته مؤقته حتى يوم
14/8 حتى من اجل تنفيذ اتفاق
145 مع حماس ونحن على تواصل مع حماس لهذا
الغرض قبل اربع ايام كنت في القاهره وهناك
اتفاق بيننا وبين حماس والمصريين ان نبدا
نهايه الشهر الجاري بدء المشاورات لتشكيل
حكومه التوافق الوطني لذلك الرئيس ابو
مازن طلب من الدكتور رامل حمض الله الخمس
اسابيع لان هذا ينسجم مع مع القانون اولا
وثانيا مع الاتفاق مع حماس الذي يجب ان
يتوج يوم
14/8 بتشكيل حكومه التوافق الوطني نحن جاه
طيب انتم جاهزون وحماس اجلت الموضوع استذ
نعم استاذ عزام يعني الفكره وضحت يعني
بشكل كامل استاذ مصطفى
الصواف فتح كانت جاهزه لتشكيل حكومه وفاق
الوطني وبدات المشاورات مع حماس في
القاهره في ال 14ب عشر من مايو الماضي
ولكن حماس كما يقول استاذ عزام احمد لم
تكون جاهزه فاقترحت برنامج عمل لثلاثه
اشهر لماذا
يعني انا في اعتقادي ان قياده حماس نفت كل
ما تحدث به السيد عزام الاحمد واكدت انها
جاهزه وهي الان جاهزه ولكن هل اختبرها
السيد محمود عباس بالقيام بتشكيل حكومه
وفاق وطني سيد محمود عباس هرب من هذه
المساله وتوجه باتجاه تشكيله بديله لسلام
فياض على نفس النهج والسياسه والسيد محمود
عباس لازال ينظر على امل ان يكون هناك
وراء ه هذه الجوله المكوكيه لجون كيري في
المنطقه امكانيه للعوده الى طاوله
المفاوضات ولا اعتقد ان طاوله المفاوضات
والمصالحه الفلسطينيه يلتقيان معا بهذه
الصوره وهذه المسافه لذلك المساله بالنسبه
للسيد محمود عباس شكرا لك استاذ مصطفى
صواف انتهى الوقت الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
من غزه شكرا لك نشكر ضيفنا ايضا من رمان
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي غسان الخطيب وشكرا
لضيفنا من برلين عزم الاحمد عضو اللجنه
المركزيه لحركه فتح بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه
من برنامج مراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في
قراءه جديده في مراء خبر جديد شكرا لكم
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته